okay this is just kind of a funny kind
of like closing the loop on a story
uh many of you who have watched my live
streams where we cover white house press
briefings have seen this reporter in the
room from newsmax her name is emerald
robinson
and she is um
and one of the most
shocking right-wing ideologues i've ever
come across she was recently banned from
twitter for posting wild anti-vaxx
nonsense
um including about some kind of element
called luciferase or luciferase you know
lucifer the devil that she claims is an
ingredient in vaccines
she had a temporary ban on twitter
was let off the ban and then within
hours she is now permanently banned the
daily beast so first of all if you pull
up her account it says account suspended
twitter suspends accounts which violate
the twitter rules newsmax star returns
to twitter and is permanently banned
banned hours later for vax insanity
after serving a seven day suspension for
absurdly claiming vaccines contain a
satan linked tracker emerald robinson
doubled down on those claims and was
booted from twitter now again i don't
like to joke about mental illness i'm
not joking about this
but
the views about
a satan-related element of vaccines or
whatever
these are the types of things where if
your family member was insisting on this
you might say
it might be good to see a psychiatrist
it might be good to be evaluated for
possible delusions psychosis paranoid
schizophrenia uh it's not a joke
um newsmax white house correspondent
emerald robinson has been permanently
suspended from twitter for repeatedly
violating the social platform's rules
against spreading spreading covet
misinformation
twitter initially gave robinson who has
relentlessly pushed anti-vaxx falsehoods
for a year a temporary timeout after she
posted an insanely absurd claim that the
covet vaccines contain a glowing
tracking device linked to the devil
she declared on twitter quote dear
christians the vaccines contain a
bioluminescent marker called luciferase
so that you can be tracked
read the latest book of the new
testament to see how this ends she was
banned for a week
while some vaccine research has used the
enzyme luciferase which has
bioluminescent features it is not an
ingredient of any coveted vaccines on
the market further it doesn't have any
satanic associations despite deriving
its name from the latin word lucifer
which means light bearing
besides receiving the reprimand from
twitter robinson was also benched by
newsmax over her false claims about
vaccines prior to taking robinson off
the air newsmax publicly rebuked its
controversial star okay so cut to
yesterday after serving her week-long
twitter lockout the conservative
firebrand returned to the social media
site with a fury on tuesday morning
proclaiming she was back on twitter at
least
seemingly showing thrade shade at
newsmax for sidelining her
robinson then promoted her account on
sub stack a subscription newsletter
service join me at sub stack before i'm
banned again
and then she tweeted one more thing
the new covet antibody test is called
satan
and it uses
luciferase no i'm not kidding it's not
an accident that they've given this name
to this test it's a warning
twitter decided to shut her account down
for good
um
permanently suspended for repeated
violations of covid misinformation
policy unclear whether she will be back
on the air
at uh fox news again
fox news at newsmax again
um
this to me
seems like someone who is really sick
really sick it seems almost
beyond herself it's not even she's doing
this as a calculated thing
because it'll reap some kind of
financial or other reward on the end
she's potentially just going to lose her
job and she's suspended from twitter and
it's hard to imagine too many people
would sign up for her sub stack maybe
it's viable maybe it's not
she just seems sick and unfortunately
you know with a lot of these things as
i've said before
there are unbalanced people
and it's just a matter of what do you
come across that you get fixated with
just as easily as she's obsessed with
antibody vaccine
satan you know this this type of stuff
right now and it seems to be an outlet
for a completely delusional person
disconnected from reality it could just
as easily be something else it could be
flat earth could be jfk
could be water turning frogs gay you
know whatever right it just it's it's
someone who is susceptible to this
because of something that they have
going on and it's not a joke to say in
other contexts
if you were a parent
and your 16 year old kid
started saying in serious ways that they
have these beliefs
you might say let's make an appointment
with a psychiatrist it's not a joke i'm
not trivializing mental illness when i
say it this is someone who looks very
very sick but for the good of the
broader community it's the right
decision to ban her from twitter that's
for sure